okay well thank you all
for attending i'm seth chandler i'm
a law professor at the university of
houston law center
affiliated with its health law and
policy institute and thank you for
joining me on this
october 2020 day i'm going to be talking
about a very applied
topic which is the cost of equality
which focuses on the effects of machine
learning
on concerns about equality
and we see that all the time these days
we see decisions being made or
influenced at least by machines with
respect to incarceration
admission to university that was a big
topic in the uk recently
but basically anytime you've got a
machine or a person behaving like a
machine
making a decision the issues that i
raise here are going to exist
and i'm going to show how well from
language particularly optimization
machine learning and visualization can
help us understand
what's going on in these settings and
think about the advantages and
disadvantages
of trying to correct for whatever
inequalities are created
by the machine learning system i should
add that there
are two files that are attached to this
talk the first is the data that i'm
using and the second is a copy
of this notebook so that if you don't
get something it's definitely available
to you
all right so instead of giving a very
code
laden talk there is tons of code here
but what i instead want to do is give an
applied talk in which i focus on a
particular example which is
one that has been controversial which is
the use by broward county in florida
and a company that it hired called
compass to try and make recommendations
about whether people should be released
from prison
based on machine learning algorithms
and so i'm going to focus on that data
but you should understand that the
principles that i'm using
apply to all sorts of forms of machine
learning
and uh so that there's a broad set of
theory that's being used here
all right so we've got our data um
and i've sucked it in and we've got
this data which is actually a simplified
version
of the data that was originally used but
for purposes of what i'm doing here i
actually think it's useful
for pedagogic purposes to just stick
with simplified data
we're going to do a little bit of
formatting of the data
and you'll notice by the way that i'm
going to make fairly extensive use of
resource functions which i think are the
greatest things since sliced bread
some of these are as at the moment
unpublished resource functions those are
things that i've looked at
if you want them you can find them on
the website
the wolfram cloud website for me others
are published resource
functions um but anyway i actually make
fairly heavy use and what we're going to
do
is we're going to separate our data into
what are called minorities
that's a sort of an american term for uh
ethnic racial groups that in the overall
population constitute a minority such as
persons of african descent
asians this construct called hispanics
native americans or indians other
indigenous people
however for the imprisoned population in
broward county they're actually a
majority
of that population but nonetheless i
will refer to them
as minorities and i will refer to
everybody else as majority so we're
taking a look at this data here
and we've split it up into majority and
minority and let's get forward again
okay all right so what would the world
look like
before machine learning and it would
turn out that about 55 percent of the
population
who is return exits incarceration
remains law-abiding for the per for the
period of time that was
measured and so if you didn't have
machine learning you might guess that
well everybody's going to be law abiding
that's the best guess i can make
um and therefore if you let everyone out
you would have a lot of
false positives and you'd be having 45.5
percent in inaccuracy costs but
minorities and majorities would be
treated equally because everybody would
be let out um or you could
try to say well i'm going to be random
about it and 54.48
of the time i'm going to let people out
and 45.5 percent of the people i'm going
to keep people in
again that would not that would be
racially
neutral um but you'd have even higher
inaccuracy costs of about 0.496 assuming
that you weight false positives
and false negatives as a one so that's
what the world looks like in some sense
without machine learning
lots of equality but pretty high error
costs
all right so let's do though some
machine learning
and uh we're going to do a traditional
thing of splitting the data
into uh training sets and test sets and
i'm going to have minorities
and non-minorities i saved this in case
something broke
um and we can have a composite training
and test set
and we're going to train the models on
all the data
just on minorities and just on
non-minorities and so we get an
association
of these groups to various classifier
functions again i export that in case
something blows up
um and what we then want to do is
develop classifier measurements that
look at various properties
of our classifiers on the test sets for
minorities and majorities
so that we can see how we do and
basically again we're going to get an
association
of various groups to these classifier
measurement objects
and if we barrel down we're going to see
the
key result here and this is what has
people upset and it's definitely worth
considering so if we look at how our
model does
on minorities versus non-minorities what
we find
is that for example the true positive
rate the models are essentially
equally accurate on each of these groups
and actually the models do a little
better on the minorities
but um what we see is that the true
positive rates
are higher for the majority than for the
minority that is of people who would not
recidivate
if given the chance a higher fraction
are let out
of majorities than minorities and of
uh people who would not recidivate i'm
sorry who would recidivate if left out
we find that we're letting out a high
fraction of majorities anyway
whereas we are confining a larger
fraction
of minorities and so one of the key
results and one of the things that has
people upset
is hey this machine learning model seems
to be
biased of it's saying of minorities who
actually would abide by the law
it is not letting them out as a higher
rate as it is for majorities
so um the question is
why is this happening that is i don't
think i'm not aware that the people at
wolfram research cleverly
biased their machine learning algorithms
so that whenever it saw a race it
discriminated on the basis of race they
didn't do that
um and it's not that the model is less
accurate on minorities
and it could be well
the machine's just doing the right thing
minorities recidivate more frequently
they have a lower incidence of
law-abiding class except that that has a
hard time explaining
why we have these two phenomenon of true
positive inequality
minorities who would be law abiding if
released are recommended for parole at a
lower rate
and we have false positive inequality
this is sort of the white
privilege problem of people from the
majority
who commit crimes are being recommended
for release at a higher rate
than minorities and so there's been a
big controversy in rebuttals and ser
rebuttals and scholarly papers looking
into this
and i thought this would be a good
opportunity for wolf from language and
mathematica
to try and figure out what's going on so
let's see
and i do have an answer as to what's
going on um so
uh in general we need to think about
machine learning and utility functions
and
thresholds so the idea here is what what
classifiers generally do
in general they develop probabilities
a distribution over potential output
classes for each individual and they'll
say
you know for this particular prisoner we
think it's forty percent likely they'll
recidivate
and sixty percent likely they'll abide
and so
if you weight a false positive the same
as a false negative then
the choice of what the classifier should
do in order to maximize expected utility
is quite clear it should say well it's
more likely than not that they're going
to law
abide by the law so let's let them free
and so
however however supposing a false
positive the willy horton story for
those who remember that
of the parolee who goes on a murder
rampage
that's a pretty heavy score and yes we'd
prefer to
let law-abiding people out but being
locked up in prison this person
says is not as bad and so if that were
the case
you would maximize utility by predicting
you sid of it
recidivate and so this is a little bit
of the math of it we can abstract away
we can expand this math to multi-class
scenarios
we can come up with a formula and this
is
just basic use of of wolfram language uh
algebra and so what you would end up at
the end of the day
is to realize that there's essentially a
one-to-one correspondence
between the ratio of disutility placed
between false positives
and false negatives and the probability
threshold that you want to see before
you let someone free
and so what you can therefore do
is think of
not just a single measure of false
positives and false negatives
or a single confusion matrix classifying
people
in based on the reality and the
prediction
but rather a trajectory of confusion
matrices and statistics derived there
from
in which you base it on a
a utility function which different
utilities
are accorded to false negatives or false
positives
or equivalently a different threshold is
required
of probability before you let someone
free
and so what we're now going to do is
actually see that
so for example here what i can do is
here is our confusion matrix done with
the wolfram convention of reality being
on the rows and here are little labels
of true negative false positive all this
stuff
and as we change our threshold we can
see the confusion matrix start to change
various statistics of those confusion
matrices start to change
or we can change the incidence of
law-abidingness in the population
against c changes
we can see what happens to inaccuracy
costs as i change the cost of a false
positive
or a false negative and the main purpose
of this particular manipulate
is to just fortify your intuition that
in fact there's a trajectory
of confusion matrices and associated
statistics
that varies as i vary the threshold
requirement
for letting someone out or equivalently
alter the utility ratios
of making various forms of mistake all
right
and so we can see for example what
effect
that has on uh the statistics so
if i for example were to lower the
threshold
to let a minority person out let's lower
it to 0.3
what we can see is that there is a
change down here
in the associated statistics and now in
fact
by doing that much i've let minorities
the false positive rates and true
positive rates
be higher than they were for uh
majorities
um you also notice uh that i tried to
mask the fact that my code was slow by
using little buttons here rather than
having sliders
and so uh what i developed was a
resource function
that actually can enable this sort of
computation more quickly
um and this is one of the resource
functions and i just had a very good
discussion they can't bail
out about how this might uh be put more
directly
this functionality might be placed more
directly into things like classifier
measurements but
we're going to end up here is an
interpolating function
that goes from a parameter which is a
threshold value the threshold we were
required to let someone free
to a confusion matrix
okay so we've got that and once we have
that we can have all sorts of fun
um so one thing we can look at is a
what's called a receiver operating curve
usually presented in two dimensions
but i actually think that has a flat
land effect of losing some valuable
information
and so this is a three-dimensional
receiver operating curve
in which we see the trajectory sweeping
out
of uh false positive rates true positive
rates which is sometimes called recall
as we vary the threshold that's required
before we let someone
free and these red dots and blue dots
represent the points at which
we have an intersection and so as i vary
the threshold
you can see those red dots and blue dots
moving and this is basically capturing
the notion
of disparate treatment of minorities and
non-minorities
we can also see this in a more
traditional way if we simply look at it
from the top
and that's that's a much more
traditional view
of the receiver operating curve but what
it shows
is again this notion that although the
model
actually works better on
minorities than it does on
non-minorities and i apologize there's
some issue with the coloring here which
after the talk i will sort through um
but what you can see
is that um the
even though the classifier is not
working quite as well
on majorities nonetheless because of
higher incidence
they are having a higher false positive
rate
higher true positive rate basically
they're being let out and we could also
see this
if you didn't want to go through all
that in a more traditional
form here so um
what we might want to do is to adjust
supposing we think this is unfair
it's unfair it's wrong
that if i take a person who is a
minority
and if i let them out they would be law
abiding i should let them out
just the same as if they were a member
of the majority
and so one way to do that might be to
use different thresholds
to say that for a minority i'll let you
out if i think there's a 30
chance you'll be law abiding for a
majority member it's got to be 60
percent
um there the disadvantage of doing it
that way is i'm going to make my
classifier less accurate
than it was before i'm going to
basically deliberately sabotage
the accuracy goal of the classifier in
order to attain greater
equal treatment among various subgroups
so we have a trade-off here and
one of the questions is how do you go
about
weakening a classifier one way would be
to change
the thresholds as i was suggesting in
the previous slide
but there are occasions in which
changing the thresholds cannot
attain various metrics of equality
then let me just go back to this graph
here
that i had earlier
previous slide previous slide
right so
if i wanted for example
i think this is the manipulative this is
the manipulator i want all right
if i wanted the true positive rate for
minorities to be the same as the true
positive rate for majority so at least i
was
treating people who would be law abiding
the same i could simply lower the
threshold for minorities to some extent
and if i do it just right there we go
we've got approximate equality there
and so um
i can achieve that metric of equality
but if i confine myself
to this roc curve there's nothing i can
do other than get
very very low thresholds or very
very high thresholds which are very
costly to get
equality in both false positive rates
and true positive rates
which is what some advocates have called
for that's called an equal odds measure
and if you look at the end of this paper
i've got a bunch of resources the the
leading paper is the one by
heart and cerebro and that's the term
that they use and they also seem to be
advocating for equal odds as a metric
so um in order to get inside
the roc curve we need to actually weaken
the classifier
and there are various ways of weakening
the classifier one is to blur the data
if the data isn't as good the classifier
can't do as good a job
and so maybe you bin the
um a number of prior arrests
or maybe instead of taking a person's
real data
you just draw a person randomly from the
set of all prisoners and you use that
and so you can see here that we can
weaken
the roc curve for a classifier by
blurring the data and you might think
well that's absurd but in fact i i
happen to know that in houston where i
live
this is the system that's used to
admit people into various schools with
advanced curriculum
they basically bin data to an extent
that they get greater quality in true
positive rates and false positive rates
among various ethnic groups and their
success
in these more accelerated programs or
another thing you can do is flipping the
idea is to say well our classifier
predicts that you're going to be
negative that you're going to recidivate
but some random fraction of the time
we're going to
flip that to a positive result and a
potentially different percentage of time
we're going to flip a positive result to
a negative result and so by doing it
that way
you can move your classifier into the
interior
of your data set so here in fact i'm
trying to get
the minority we gotta do
and if i jiggle the threshold a little
bit
all sorts of fun things can happen but i
can basically achieve equality
through a combination of flipping and
adjusting the threshold so that's
another mechanism
for achieving these more sophisticated
methods
of equality and finally and this is what
the
the heart suivo group recommended is to
use a stochastic threshold
to not say it's always 50 maybe
sometimes
it's 30 percent likelihood that it's
required to get out
other times it's 70 percent likely to
get out
and you can kind of see how this works
here
where um if i let's let's set
the majority let's sink the majority
did i sync it come on sync okay so
that's my majority that's my
target um and what do i have to do
well let's see if i weaken this
and then i wait i need to weight this
one some more
uh what do i have to do here
i want to move this up here in any event
um if i do this enough i can you can
always
get the big red dot to line up over the
little blue dot
and achieve equality and and one of you
know the case for doing this by a
computer
you just saw made by the fact that i
didn't do a very good job
trying to do it by hand and in fact
in the next
in one of the slides you'll see me using
some optimization techniques
to try and get the two dots to fall over
each other
and achieve these other metrics of
equality the problem is that every time
i do that
i am weakening the accuracy of the
classifier
um and so this uh you know this um
manipulate here is going to show
how much i'm weakening it in order to
achieve equality and so in fact here i
guess i basically solved it
and see that the total inequality costs
went up from 616 when i just left things
alone
and they've gone up to 716 as a result
of my efforts to achieve equality
now is that a good thing or a bad thing
i suppose it depends on the context
and how much you value equal treatment
um the only point that i want to make
here
is that there are in fact costs of
achieving that particular metric
of equality and oh here's the
optimization problem
all right so we got compiled functions
using the new compiler the old compiler
blah blah blah and as a since i'm
running out of time
let me just show you an end up result
here which is i think if you know you
want one picture here's the picture
so these are different metrics
that you might want to use in
determining
how to administer a test how to
administer a machine learning algorithm
and here are the costs of equality
uh that result uh costs of the
inaccuracy costs
that result and you know how do you
minimize inaccuracy costs well you
set it you tell the machine minimizing
accuracy costs and that gets you the
lowest result
um what's the worst thing it's this
equal odds measure where you're trying
to get
both the false positive rate and true
positive rate
to be the same and then there are
various intermediates here and again
does going from 0.33 to 0.39 is that
fatal should we give up on our goal of
equality
that's sort of a decision that's
somewhat above my pay grade but at least
we've identified
what the cost might be the issue comes
though if you insist on equal
odds there is generally always going to
be
some intersection of classifications for
which the classifier doesn't perform
well like maybe female native americans
we don't have very many of them in
prison
so we might not have very good data or
maybe it doesn't work very well on male
whites over 60.
and if we insist on the classifier
being dumbed down so that it performs to
the level that it does on the weakest
group
we could have quite significant
increases in inequality costs and what
the next
segment of this does is it turns out the
classifier doesn't do very well on what
i call
hardened criminals these are people who
have more than 10 prior
arrests um and so
what i'm going to show here by the end
of the day after a lot of code
uh you can see the the roc curve on
hardened criminals is nothing to be
proud of
um and we keep going down and we keep
doing it and you should read this in the
paper and download it and study it at
great length
but at the end of the day you can see
that moving
up to equal odds causes an increase in
an accuracy cost from 0.33
to 0.55 and you know depending on what
those units
are um that could potentially be very
troubling all right
so what are the political implications
of the research
um it does suggest that maybe we we you
know
in law there are various doctrine the
various theories that are approved
for what the united states is called
affirmative action uh
basically giving certain forms of
preferences to certain forms of
historically underrepresented groups
most of those legal theories have
actually been rejected by the supreme
court in its present condition
but this is suggesting that either
incidence bias or weakness in
classifiers
might be a basis for granting some
preference
to uh disadvantaged groups to compensate
for the problems of the classifier
but what it also does is to me it
suggests a good deal of caution
in going to certain measures of
inequality particularly the equal odds
one that
my friends at uh heart and cebo and the
like are recommending
uh so uh i think
with that here are some references this
is as i said if you want to read one
paper
this is probably the paper that you
should read this is probably the paper
that's closest to mine but not nearly as
good
um and this is how you can get in touch
with me
and i will stop there and look at the
chat
so assuming i can figure out how to do
this
hey here we go all right
so if i look at the chat what i see is
that no one's chatting
all right the page okay refresh the page
all right
um and also i'm going to
share the screen somehow
so that it captures the
chat well just capture my whole screen
what the heck
okay so with different classifiers
used by type of crime right so
the underlying data as i remember it uh
may have some information on it on type
of crime it basically has distinctions
between felonies
and misdemeanors and yes i agree
that that letting a felon out might be
much more significant than letting a
shoplifter out
um or drug possession and murder as you
say
um and um
i wanted to create a simplified
pedagogic presentation here and so i
used the simplified version of the data
um but the theories are all the same
that is the fact that both the
classifier works better on both
minorities and majorities by adding
certain forms of
data does not eliminate the underlying
problem that the classifier tends to
perform
differently based on racial subgrouping
and then you have the issue that i've
raised which is what are we going to do
about it
uh dave dubrow asks utility function and
classified useful
and the answer is damn right useful it's
it's you know critical
to getting the kind of results that i'm
getting and so
if you look at i think some of the
resource functions that i've put up or
will put up
um they're adjusting the
parameters of the utility function as a
sort of a way of changing the threshold
of probability that's required so i hope
that's helpful
to your question
uh if there are other questions i'd be
happy to entertain them
in the chat otherwise i think i'm going
to turn into a pumpkin here
but if anyone wants to further discuss
this or additions or suggestions
um is the solution getting more data
i suppose in theory if one had
infinite data
then any differences in recidivism that
one saw
would in fact be caused some extent by
race and you might wanna
um uh
but what we find is that
even if the classifier performs
equivalently that is even if when
viewed in two dimensions the roc curve
is the same
for two groups nonetheless you're going
to see
um the problem is bigger than than
simply not having enough data the
problem is that if the
incidence levels of the positive class
differ by racial groupings you will tend
to get
higher false positive rates and higher
true positive rates
in the group for which the incidence is
higher
and that is from many people's
perspective a problem that is
the problem that i've identified here
unless you ended up with a perfect model
on all subgroups which strikes me as
unlikely in most practical settings
the problem i've identified here will
persist now
it may be that correcting it has lower
costs in those settings
um but this is not simply a problem
of not having enough data
uh yes causality you know
the these these claps do not presently
understand
causality and to be sure you know
the ideal solution would be to set up an
environment in which people didn't
commit crimes and so you would give them
education
support and better family and better
access to housing and all those other
things
that would tend to reduce crime that
that you know that problem is definitely
above
my abilities um yes
so dave asks basically he wants to know
um about um
shouldn't there be degrees of recidivism
uh and in fact again
the underlying data distinguishes
between what it calls violent recidivism
and non-violent recidivism and it has
different
subgroups for that um and
certainly i i want to take a look at
that and have taken a look at that
actually
for my pedagogic purposes again i wanted
to just
abstract away those details and focus on
the more
fundamental problem which is going to
persist
which is that if there is a difference
in incidence
among the various groups the classifier
is likely to have
behavior that many people find
unpalatable on the other hand fixing
that by modifying for example thresholds
can will make the classifier less
accurate
and less accurate classifiers can have
big problems if you're now letting out
people
that are likely to commit serious crimes
or
similarly incarcerating people who
really would be just fine if you let
them out and you're you know you're
letting them rot
in prison at their expense in the
expense of society
so um there's some additional questions
by dave
on um measuring i would say the
harm and getting better data
and you know absolutely i agree that
that better data
might be useful in both making decisions
and doing classifiers
i'm limited to the data that i have
and the data that compass and the like
uh collected which is
not perhaps as granular as one would
like and with that i think
i i don't know if i have to do anything
ed to call this to a halt
but um uh so magically make me disappear
thank you all for attending
thanks for your questions and look
forward to hearing from the rest of you
at the conference